[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 sur TV 78
c'est votre émission pour bien démarrer
la soirée dans les Yvelines avec au menu
et de l'actualité des Infopratique et
des idées de sortie voici le programme
de ce 6 décembre
l'hôpital André Mignot pense s'épelet
après la cyberattaque dont il a été
victime ce week-end l'activité du site
installée au cheneroc en cours et très
perturbé le système informatique coupé
pour limiter les dégâts pourquoi les
hôpitaux sont-ils visés par les pirates
ces établissements sont-ils plus
vulnérables que d'autres pierre delec
expert en cybersécurité et notre invité
Bougival veut mener la vie dure au mégot
de cigarettes la ville a mise en place
vaincu en laiton au niveau des bouches
d'égout avec ce message ne rien jeter
ici commence la mer chaque agent de
propreté passerait une heure par jour au
ramassage des mégots selon la mairie
et puis il se rend concerne le 16
décembre prochain sur la scène du
théâtre Coluche de plaisir l'artiste qui
se présente comme un poète funambule il
s'agit d'Alexis HK jouera son nouvel
album bobo playground il chante avec
l'humour mais sans cynisme avec
tendresse mais sans fader Alexis HK sera
avec nous à tout à l'heure dans le 7 8
ce sera dans notre partie culture et on
y parlera aussi du prix youtuber
d'histoire lycéen 2022 pour la deuxième
année consécutive il a été remis à
l'occasion du salon histoire de lire à
Versailles c'était en novembre le
lauréat de cette année est avec nous en
plateau c'est Maxence de lacrouet
bonsoir bonsoir Monsieur alors vous avez
été primé grâce à votre vidéo je vous
présente très brièvement vous êtes élève
de premier au lycée Blanche de Castille
c'est au Chesnay Rocancourt et le titre
de votre vidéo pour laquelle vous avez
été primé si on a toujours la patate
grâce à Parmentier on en dit pas plus
pour le moment et on parlera du sujet
tout à l'heure d'où vient déjà cette
passion pour l'histoire depuis toujours
en fait depuis que je suis en primaire
c'est vrai que c'était une des dire que
j'aimais le plus j'ai toujours aimé
savoir à un tel événement qui s'est
passé dans l'histoire qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé et finalement quels sont les
conséquences qui en résulte aujourd'hui
au 21e siècle et c'est vrai que après au
collège et au lycée j'ai continué à
adorer cette matière et les spécialités
que je fais aujourd'hui sont finalement
enfin la géopolitique donc c'est vrai
que c'est un peu en accord avec avec ce
que j'aime donc l'histoire et pourquoi
l'utiliser au travers de la vidéo là
cette fois-ci c'était le format vidéo
qui était demandé le format de youtubeur
finalement est-ce que c'est intéressant
d'utiliser la vidéo justement pour
parler d'histoire oui parce que je pense
que la vidéo est un des meilleurs moyens
pour pour transmettre une connaissance
en histoire à un public gérer et vous
avez été primé parmi 10 candidatures on
aura l'occasion tout à l'heure de parler
de cette vidéo on a toujours la patate
grâce à parmentier au menu aussi le
temps des humains c'est le nom de ce
nouveau spectacle de la compagnie Pixum
avec nous également en plateau c'est
Charlie formantik et avec nous bonsoir
vous êtes la directrice artistique de la
compagnie pic mais vous allez donc
présenter ce nouveau spectacle je le
disais son titre c'est le temps des
humains ce sera du 16 décembre au 15
janvier au Petit Moulin des Vaux de
Cernay avant de parler du spectacle la
compagnie Pixum pour ceux qui ne la
connaissent pas en quelques mots c'est
quoi alors c'est une compagnie de
théâtre
déambulatoire on fait des spectacles
immersif et interactifs dans des lieux
d'histoire dans des lieux du département
du 78 et on utilise notre patrimoine à
la fois écologie et architecturale pour
raconter des histoires ou les
spectateurs seront en situation
complètement immersive tout est prêt
pour la semaine prochaine tout est prêt
tout va bien il faut toujours être vrai
et on parlera plus en détail de ce
spectacle dans quelques instants en
deuxième partie d'émission aussi à
suivre dans le 7 8 les informations du
jour avec notre journaliste Michael el
mis Doro bonsoir on parlera notamment
alors on montrera même plus précisément
des images impressionnantes oui une
image enfin des images spectaculaires
celle du grutage vous connaissez
forcément le bassin d'A dans les jardins
du château de Versailles et bien il va
être déplacé pour être totalement
restauré ça apprend 18 mois et
aujourd'hui ils ont justement enlevé les
fameuses statues d'Apollon pour les
emmener en rénovation et ce sera dans un
instant dans le 7 8 l'épisode 2 aussi
dans cette émission de notre série sur
le chef yvelinois Jérémy en bielle nous
le suivons toute cette semaine dans la
préparation d'un de ces plats la poule
au pot avec comme ingrédient principal
un ingrédient qui se nomme la poule de
Houdan un ingrédient classique dans les
Yvelines bien sûr et comme chaque mardi
d'ailleurs l'astuce du chef aussi à
retrouver dans le 7 8 pour briller chez
vous en cuisine et cette semaine c'est
le chef étoilé Jean-Baptiste Lavergne
Morazzani kissicole mais avant tout cela
petit coup d'œil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera brumeux dans
les Yvelines à Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et
Rambouillet du côté de Versailles les
nuages seront bien présents au niveau
des températures couvrez-vous bien car
il fera 2 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles et un degré à Houdan est
Rambouillet et dans l'après-midi le ciel
va rester couvert sur l'ensemble du
département l'hiver s'installe au niveau
des températures il fera 5 à 4 degrés en
moyenne ce mardi 6 décembre c'est la
sainte Ambroise
et tout de suite les informations du
jour avec vous Michael elmidoro et on
prend tout de suite la direction de
Versailles pour notre image du jour au
château de Versailles spectaculaire
opération de grutage s'est déroulé ce
mardi matin l'objectif restaurer le
fameux bassin du char d'Apollon situé
dans les jardins dans la continuité du
château l'ensemble a été retiré pour
être acheminé dans un atelier les 13
cultures en plomb seront entièrement
restaurés redorées au total le projet va
nécessiter 18 mois de chantier n'écoute
Catherine péga la présidente du château
de Versailles c'est d'abord une immense
émotion pour nous tous ce matin parce
qu'on a le sentiment de vivre un moment
totalement inédit presque historique si
on n'avait pas peur des grands mots en
assistant à cette ce départ d'Apollon
pour cette grande restauration que l'on
attendait depuis longtemps c'est une
restauration qui a été urgente comme on
a pu vous le montrer et comme on peut le
voir on voit de près que ces sculptures
sont extrêmement abîmées mais que aussi
tout ce bassin a besoin d'une d'une
grande restauration voilà pour ces
images impressionnantes du côté du
château de Versailles de notre image du
jour on passe aussi à notre chiffre du
jour c'est 80 aujourd'hui ce weekend 80
% des serveurs aurait été touchés par la
cyberataque de l'hôpital de Versailles
c'est le premier bilan dressé par les
responsables de la structure une attaque
massive qui va empêcher l'hôpital d'être
à 100% de ses capacités pendant
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
la question aujourd'hui de savoir si oui
ou non la propagation du virus
informatique est terminée ce qui semble
être le cas mais les autorités restent
prudentes on a appris aussi que ces
dernières heures ces dernières heures
que l'hôpital a subi plusieurs attaques
ces derniers mois mais jamais de cette
ampleur cette cyberattaque a eu
d'énormes conséquences sur le secteur
hospitalier du sud-yvelines qui a été
totalement déstabilisée de nombreux à
patientes étaient transportées à plaisir
ou encore à Rambouillet dans un instant
avec notre invité on prend à présent la
direction de Clairefontaine alors pour
une on y parle pas de foot dans le sud
des Yvelines alors dans le cadre de la
Semaine des lycées à professionnels
plusieurs tables auront été organisés au
Centre national du football à
Clairefontaine ce mardi s'il décembre
objectif des lycéens de l'académie de
Versailles en présenté le métier de leur
rêve à des collégiens les mêlant avec
l'ambiance footballistique du site de
Clairefontaine il y avait notamment des
ateliers sur la sécurité l'hôtellerie
les espaces verts ont encore la
restauration on écoute les réactions
micro de régime ralech alors aujourd'hui
les élèves lycéens il y a une douzaine
de lycées représentés avec donc 12
formations sur la sécurité sur l'accueil
sur
de la maintenance sur de la
cybersécurité sur de la vente et en fait
c'est de montrer que sur un site
remarquable tel que celui que nous
occupons aujourd'hui et qui nous est si
gentiment prêté c'est de pouvoir montrer
qu'il y a des métiers en lien avec le
sport qui sont un petit peu cachés et
qui contribuent mais à la réussite
peut-être des Bleus aujourd'hui
alors Élancourt on monte quelques jours
en arrière il y avait du spectacle ce
week-end le ciel s'est embrasé ce samedi
à 3 décembre la ville organisée le
spectacle dragon time du parc Vulcania
au stade Guy Boniface comme vous pouvez
le voir sur ces images spectaculaires et
festives cet événement a donné le coup
d'envoi des festivités de Noël dans la
commune il y aura notamment le marché de
Noël de la ville qui sera programmée de
ce vendredi 9 décembre à ce dimanche 11
décembre avec 32 chalets en bois les
gourmands pourront déguster des
confiserie ou encore des crêpes pour les
gourmands on termine nos infos du jour
par du sport du football très
précisément le FC Versailles continue
d'engranger les victoires dans le
championnat de National les versets se
sont imposés 2 à 0 face à ce don stade
Jean Bouin à Paris les buts sont signés
Mondi prunus à la 54e minute et Mathilde
Séville à la 65e minute de quoi ravir le
nouveau coach brésilien de l'équipe
Chris les joueurs de la cité royale sont
à la deuxième place du classement après
14 journées disputées ils ne sont qu'à
quatre petits points du leader concar
bravo au verset on a une petite pensée
pour le coach brésilien Chris qui a
peut-être manqué la qualification du
Brésil pour les quarts de finale et de
la Coupe du monde en question en ce
moment au Qatar il a dû regarder le
replay je pense qu'il a dû regarder le
replay merci Michael pour toutes ces
informations et si vous aussi près de
chez vous vous êtes témoin d'un fake qui
vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas à le dire
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news
[Musique]
80 pour cent des serveurs informatiques
de l'hôpital André Mignot du centre
hospitalier de Versailles touché par une
cyberattaque nous avons relayé cette
donnée cette donnée d'ampleur pour
l'hôpital une victime qui a été victime
l'hôpital d'une cyberattaque ce week-end
on rappelle que l'établissement est
situé au Chesnay Rocancourt conséquences
un accueil des patients réorganisés le
plan blanc qui a été déclenché sur place
des perturbations qui vont impacter
l'hôpital pendant plusieurs semaines
pourquoi en est-on arrivé là pourquoi
viser l'hôpital quelle problématique
soulève cette actualité on va poser
toutes ces questions à Pierre delec qui
est avec nous par visioconférence
bonsoir
de l'entreprise silicom qui a fait
partie du groupe prophétie alors cette
entreprise est basée à Guyancourt et à
la campagne les entreprises de tous les
secteurs dans leur stratégie en cyber
sécurité c'est la deuxième cyberathèque
du genre en quelques mois qui vise
directement un hôpital en août dernier
c'est le centre hospitalier
sud-francilien en Essonne qui avait été
aussi victime d'une cyberattaque
pourquoi les hôpitaux sont des cibles de
choix pour les hackers
je pense que toutes les administrations
sont des cibles de choix pour l'acte les
hackers pardon puisque c'est des cibles
qui vont avoir énormément de personnels
qui vont pouvoir potentiellement cliquer
sur un mail malicieux ou sur un système
divers et lancer cette cyber attaque je
pense pas que ce soit forcément quelque
chose qui soit ciblé par contre une fois
que les hackers sont rentrés dans le
système ça fait des cibles de choix
puisque ces sites très importantes et
qui à chaque fois touche aussi un des
administrations publiques et aussi des
collectivités qui ont été touchées par
ces cyberatech d'ailleurs si on regarde
les deux cyberata qui sont produits sur
ces deux hôpitaux là on Essonne l'un
l'autre dans les Yvelines et ce qu'on
est sur des cyberattaques qui sont
similaires est-ce que c'est le même
procédé à chaque fois qui est utilisé
à chaque fois on est sur des
cyberattaques par rançongiciel donc
c'est à dire des cyberattaques qui
consistent à prendre en otage les
données à prendre en otage les systèmes
d'information et à demander le paiement
d'une rançon entre guillemets pour
récupérer l'accès au système l'accès aux
données donc l'intérêt pour ces pirates
c'est de pouvoir on va dire bloquer en
quelques sortes ces données d'exiger une
rançon c'est ça tout l'intérêt pour pour
les pirates c'est pour ça aussi qui
s'entraîne à ce type d'établissement
oui ben effectivement l'idée c'est de
pouvoir récupérer cette rançon après
effectivement la doctrine de l'État est
de ne pas payer puis dans ces cas-là
donc c'est vrai que ça rend le système
un petit peu compliqué pour les pirates
et les hackers mais effectivement c'est
c'est quand même l'objectif principal
c'est de dire je bloque le service je
bloque l'usage et j'espère que mes
interlocuteurs vont payer pour que je
développe un système mais ce qu'on peut
partir du principe que ces données sont
définitivement perdus même si il y a
paiement d'une éventuelle rançon
alors c'est l'hypothèse qu'on fait
toujours c'est à dire que vous faites
quand même un marché avec un avec des
criminels et ces criminels vous dites
bah oui je vous garantis que si vous me
donnez de l'argent je vais vous donner
la clé pour ouvrir vos données donc on
peut considérer que dans ce format-là
les données sont probablement perdu
après il faut compter sur les différents
systèmes de sauvegarde de procédure qui
vont permettre de le retour à l'activité
donc ce qu'on appelle les plans de
retour d'activité les plans de
continuité d'activité est-ce que les
patients peut-être il y en a parmi nos
téléspectateurs peuvent être inquiets
sur leur sur leurs données ils peuvent
avoir un motif d'inquiétude quant à leur
donner personnel l'utilisation de ces
données personnelles de leur donner de
patient du coup et ce qu'ils peuvent
être inquiets
à date on peut rien dire après
effectivement il peut y avoir une
inquiétude légitime de la part des
patients puisque les données ont bel et
bien été attaqués elles ont été animés
chiffrées par les hackers et
potentiellement une partie a pu être
extraite pour être revendu
potentiellement plus offrant à d'autres
mais on a vu que 5 études avait été
notamment en soulevé lors de la cyberata
qui avait visé je le disais le centre
hospitalier sud-francier c'était en août
du côté de l'Essonne les conséquences à
court terme on les connaît on voit
qu'aujourd'hui les services de l'hôpital
Mignot sont au ralenti les conséquences
à plus long terme quels sont-elles à
votre avis
les conséquences à plus long terme c'est
quand on est sur quand même sur le
deuxième hôpital qui subit ce type
d'attaque c'est certainement pas le
dernier service public qui va ce type
d'attaque c'est je pense que les
conséquences internes c'est une
meilleure organisation du qu'on va
appeler le Plan de Continuité d'Activité
aujourd'hui on arrive à la limite du
Plan de Continuité d'Activité qui est
purement papier en disant ben c'est pas
grave si on a plus d'informatique on va
retourner au bon vieux formulaire papier
on va tout traiter on voit
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
compliqué de retourner à
papier crayon et simplement même pour le
fonctionnement d'un hôpital donc il faut
que nos hôpitaux soient mieux préparés
que nos administrations nous soient
mieux préparées dans le cadre de ces
attaques et de ses interruptions de
service
au-delà des hôpitaux c'est toutes les
administrations administrations
publiques en général qui sont visées je
disais aussi tout à l'heure il y a des
collectivités qui ont été visés par ce
type de cyberatex ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui très concrètement elles
sont pas assez protégés face à ce type
de menace
je pense que c'est pas qu'une question
de protection c'est une question de
préparation et la préparation fait
partie effectivement la protection mais
on est plus sur une question de
aujourd'hui la ce qu'on dit souvent
c'est est-ce que pas est-ce que je vais
être attaqué mais quand vais-je être
attaqué et plutôt c'est comment je me
prépare à au jour d'après de l'attaque
et de faire en sorte que Ben tout mon
système soit fluide après cette attaque
et pour terminer quel conseil vous vous
donneriez justement sur cette thématique
que ses administrations se préparent
davantage peut-être aussi plus de moyens
sur cette protection face au
cybercriminel
mais il y a les deux sujets il y a le
volet des cyberprotections même si on
est dans des environnements qui sont
relativement complexes puisque c'est des
panels il n'y a pas que des PC dans le
cadre d'une d'une entreprise enfin d'une
administration comme l'hôpital il y a
énormément de d'outils médicaux que ce
soit des scanners des IRM qui peuvent
être connectés qui peuvent
potentiellement être des vecteurs
d'attaque on souvient par exemple dans
le cadre TV5 Monde les pirates étaient
rentrés au travers de caméra vous avez
pris le
il s'est avéré réussi à pivoter au
travers de caméra connectée donc ça peut
être tous ces équipements là qui sont
des portes d'entrée des portes dérobées
pour les hackers pour pouvoir déployer
leur attaque parce que souvent on dit
que c'est un utilisateur mais ça peut
être plein d'autres équipements qui
peuvent être tout le sujet de la
protection et surtout le sujet de la
préparation à la crise malheureusement
aujourd'hui ça va être des choses qui
sont de plus en plus communes il faut
travailler sur ces scénarios de
préparation scénarios de crise pour que
l'ensemble des
parties prenantes soient prêtes
merci Pierre de like d'avoir été avec
nous merci à vous je rappelle si tio de
l'entreprise silicom une entreprise de
cyber sécurité basé à Guyancourt et dans
le reste de l'actualité je vous en
parlais dans les titres la ville de
Bougival veut sensibiliser les fumeurs
contre les gènes mégots dans l'espace
public depuis novembre dernier 20 clous
en laiton ne rien jeter ici comment cela
mer ont été installés au niveau des
bouches d'égouts l'objectif c'est de
faire prendre conscience que cette
incivilité en ville peut avoir des
conséquences sur nos océans le reportage
de Julien Leroy donc vous avez des
résidus de mégot là
derrière
et là il y a un amas là
mairie de Bougival passe à l'action des
clous en laiton ont été installés en
novembre au niveau des avaloirs d'eau de
la commune objectif de ce dispositif ne
rien jeter ici commence la mer rappeler
aussi ton lien les conséquences aux
environnementsales du G2 mégot dans
l'espace public la présence de ces clous
généralement présents en bord de mer
peut surprendre dans une ville Yves
linoise Bougival est une ville d'eau
puisque nous sommes le long de la Seine
et tous les mégots qui arrivent par les
offres pluviales dans les avaloirs se
déverse dans la Seine en masse et suit
donc le parcours de la Seine et se jette
dans la mer
pour un coup de 2000 euros à la commune
Bougival espère un investissement
utile chaque agent de propreté passe une
heure par jour au ramassage des mégots
selon la mairie c'est très difficile de
verbaliser les personnes
la démarche aujourd'hui deux Bougival et
de sensibiliser de manière pédagogique
après effectivement elle est juste
devant la bouche donc la personne qui
arrive avec son mégot juste devant la
bouche il y a la poubelle à côté donc il
fera peut-être justement l'effort de le
mettre dans la poubelle je sais pas si
ça si ça servira en tout cas c'est joli
tout ça toujours très sympa
effectivement de faire prendre
conscience aux gens que Ben attention la
mère c'est pas des milliers de
kilomètres c'est là c'est tout de suite
maintenant alors ça va pas les empêcher
de fumer ça peut peut-être leur donner
mauvaise conscience si j'ai être par
terre mais voilà je pense pas que je
pense pas que ça va faire changer leur
habitude d'après une étude de la
Commission européenne les mégots de
cigarettes sont le déchet plastique le
plus retrouvé sur les plages européennes
derrière les bouteilles le ministère de
la transition écologique estime entre 20
000 et 25000 tonnes la quantité de mégot
jetés en France chaque année
la suite à présent dans le 7 8 de notre
série consacrée à la confection de la
poule au pot par le chef Jérémy en
bielle ce soir le chef va chercher ses
ingrédients pour réaliser sa recette
direction et la boucherie des arts et le
magasin de fruits et légumes be fruits à
Houdan avec Nicolas dandry et Mathilde
Franco
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous propose de cuisiner
la poule au pot avec la poule de Houdan
et pour ça je vous propose de
m'accompagner et de voir tous les locaux
avec qui je travaille au quotidien donc
la première étape c'est d'aller à la
boucherie des arts sur sur Houdan pour
récupérer de quoi faire la farce pour la
poule au pot et aussi la pièce du
boucher pour le restaurant pour le
service du jour salut
[Musique]
salut tout le monde bonjour Jérémy ça va
très bien
haché alors ça c'est du veau de lait
sous la mer qui vient
serrer 100%
naturel
un veau qui a été élevé pendant six mois
donc pour la farce ça va être impeccable
on travaille ensemble dans un dans un
domaine où il y a un restaurant
bistronomie on essaie de faire la
qualité de produits sachant qu'on veut
qu'on veut que la qualité que la qualité
on travaille 100% de françaises on
travaille avec des éleveurs de région
de l'Auvergne de Limousin du Lot ce qui
est important avec Jérémy c'est que on
travaille avec l'éleveur de l'éleveur en
jusqu'à la cuisine jusqu'à dans
l'assiette Loïc travaille sur de la bête
entière donc du coup c'est aussi mon but
c'est de travailler les morceaux qu'il a
besoin de distribuer donc quand il me
dit aujourd'hui c'est du faux filet
qu'il faut passer j'ai du faux-filet à
passer le lendemain ça sera peut-être de
l'entrecôte ça sera peut-être de la
honte après mais aujourd'hui l'avantage
c'est d'avoir toujours ce produit
d'exception et c'est ce que nos
consommateurs en tout cas au restaurant
recherche
pareil il me faut un peu de pièces du
boucher je prends un pâté de Houdan
aussi donc le pâté de Houdan pareil fait
avec la poule de Houdan qui sont
fabriqués par Stéphane
[Musique]
merci je vous souhaite une bonne journée
les gars et puis à tout à l'heure si
besoin ou à demain ciao ciao allez bonne
journée bon courage salut
[Musique]
maintenant on va se diriger vers notre
maraîcher donc Christophe de qui a la
boutique be free un peu plus haut sur
Houdan
[Musique]
salut salut
normalement il y a tout ce qu'il faut
vérifier si on a oublié
les oignons poireaux parfait c'est top
mais bon c'est bon il y a tout
[Musique]
bon je te remercie pour tout et puis je
te dis je passerai peut-être ça peine si
j'ai besoin ça marche allez ciao
[Musique]
maintenant on part pour la prochaine
étape donc on va vers la le volailler
Julien Lecoq de la ferme le coq
[Musique]
mais la suite demain dans le 7 8 et
restez avec nous à la fin de cette
émission on reparle cuisine avec la
recette de notre chef yvelinois pour
briller chez vous
[Musique]
mais d'abord la page culture dans le 7 8
on parle de nombreux sujets et notamment
de ce prix youtubeur d'histoire lycéen
2022 je le disais tout à l'heure il a
été remis à l'occasion du salon histoire
de lire à Versailles c'est en novembre
le lauréat est avec nous en plateau
c'est Maxence de la croué qui élève de
première au lycée blanche de cassis
c'est au Chesnay Rocancourt et je le
disais tout à l'heure vous avez remporté
ce prix grâce à votre vidéo on a
toujours la patate grâce à Parmentier ça
vous fait quoi de remporter un prix
en étant un élève aujourd'hui de de
première qu'est-ce que ça vous fait de
remporter un prix bah évidemment à la
base je m'y attendais pas du tout à
recevoir ce prix mais c'est vrai que ça
ça apporte beaucoup de satisfaction
parce que ça être récompensé du travail
qu'on a fourni c'est franchement la
meilleure chose qui puisse nous arriver
comment vous avez eu vent de ce prix et
pourquoi avoir voulu y participer alors
les derniers on m'avait déjà proposé de
faire ce prix ça venait d'une famille
d'amis qui m'avait proposé de le faire
mais c'est vrai que j'étais pas
forcément très motivé et puis j'étais
même pas sûr j'étais même pas sur Le
Chesnay c'est compliqué et puis cette
année on m'a relancé et je me suis dit
bon pourquoi pas c'était pendant les
vacances et donc pendant trois jours je
me suis je me suis j'ai fait cette vidéo
et puis et puis j'ai envoyé quoi en
disant pourquoi pas une vidéo qui met en
lumière en toile Parmentier on va
regarder tout de suite un extrait
bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour
parler d'un homme qui a su donner aux
Français un goût pour un aliment qui
nous met tous de bonne humeur et je
parle bien sûr ici de la pomme de terre
et cet homme c'est Antoine Augustin
Parmentier Parmentier est né en 1737 en
Picardie il est issu d'une famille très
modeste il va devenir apprenti
apothicaire à l'âge de 13 ans ses
parents ne l'avaient pas vraiment assez
d'argent pour l'envoyer au collège il
poursuit donc sa formation et va
s'engager dans l'âge dans l'armée à
l'âge de 20 ans en tant que pharmacien
bon entre nous s'il est parti me ramener
c'est pas pour faire le mec hein c'est
juste parce qu'il est pas assez d'argent
pour ouvrir sa propre pharmacie mais au
cours de la guerre des sept ans qui a
duré de 1756 à 1763 Parmentier et
capturé par les Prussiens et comme tout
adversaire militaire les était très
sadique avec leurs prisonnier et croyez
donc les déprimés en leur servant chaque
jour une bouillie de pommes de terre
mais Parmentier s'aperçoit que sa santé
ne se dégrade pas avec ce turbir avec ce
tubercule il est d'abord donc une
théorie selon laquelle cette plante
pourra remplacer le pain en France qui
est donc l'aliment de base des Français
en cas de mauvaise oiseau Maxence votre
sujet donc en toile Augustin Parmentier
avec plusieurs facettes celles de
pharmacien de nutritionnistes celles
surtout d'infantigables expérimentateur
au XVIIIe siècle on lui doit notamment
parce qu'il y a aussi beaucoup d'autres
travaux mais ces travaux sur la pomme de
terre qui s'est imposée peu à peu comme
un aliment phare de la nourriture des
Français c'est un tubercule qui a été
introduit en Europe suite à la
découverte de l'Amérique mais pourquoi
choisir ce sujet le sujet Parmentier
parce que la contrainte de cette vidéo
YouTube c'était ça devait rentrer dans
le programme qu'on faisait dans l'année
lycéen dans laquelle on était donc moi
j'étais en première mais je savais qu'il
je devais je devais faire la différence
par mon originalité donc il fallait que
je trouve quelque chose quelque chose
qui soit dans la période que je vais
étudier cette année en première mais que
l'on étudie pas en classe et c'est vrai
comme j'avais étudié Antoine Parmentier
dans un magazine j'avais plutôt bien
aimé son histoire je me suis dit que
c'était c'était le sujet idéal mais ça
vous a intéressé le fait aussi de voir
que au 18e siècle la pomme de terre on
ne connaissait pas forcément et
aujourd'hui quand on regarde dans la
gastronomie française ça c'est imposé
comme un aliment vraiment de base c'est
vrai que c'est assez hallucinant de voir
que en même pas 3 siècles et demi la
pomme de terre a vraiment évolué dans
dans l'assiette des Français et alors
qu'aujourd'hui enfin tout le monde mange
de la pomme de terre au quotidien tout
le temps et c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
c'était pas forcément le cas et
l'évidence pour tout le monde il y a une
recette qui parle à tout le monde là je
suis pas en entier forcément un hommage
à Antoine Parmentier vous avez mener
comment vos recherches vous avez dit
c'est parti d'un magazine vous aviez lu
quelque chose un article sur Antoine
Parmentier comment vous avez mener vos
recherches pour faire cette vidéo bah
énormément à partir de ce magazine que
j'avais lu et conserver et puis après
des recherches internet voilà donc j'ai
dû écrire un peu le script ce que je
voulais ce que je voulais dire il
fallait j'adore vraiment toutes les
facettes de sa vie et mais c'est vrai
que c'était énormément grâce à ce
magazine et vous avez découvert d'autres
choses intéressantes à son sujet au-delà
du fait que c'est le vulgarisateur de la
pomme de terre en Europe bah bien sûr
enfin c'est vrai que il y a une anecdote
surtout qui m'a énormément plu c'est le
fait que je je l'explique dans ma vidéo
mais c'est que les Français étaient à
doutés sur sur la fiabilité de cette
époque de terre il va donc placer des
gardes autour de son champ de pomme de
terre pour faire comprendre aux Français
que que c'est cette pomme de terre c'est
c'est un vrai aliment qui a de la valeur
il va aussi offrir d'ailleurs une plante
de pommes de terre au roi
entre guillemets pour pour que le
pouvoir royal certifie cette pomme de
terre et que les Français soient sûr que
c'est un aliment qui soit
de toute fiabilité donc il y a un lien
direct avec les Yvelines si ça a été
présenté dans la cour du roi
effectivement au château de Versailles
pour la réalisation de la vidéo ça s'est
passé comment est-ce que vous aviez des
notions en vidéo pas du tout c'est aussi
une découverte j'avais déjà fait oui
j'avais déjà un fond vert un
micro-cravate enfin j'avais déjà moi
j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup la vidéo
le montage etc donc ça c'était pas
vraiment à probable après j'avais un ami
venant de Nantes qui était là donc il
était derrière moi pour faire le cadrage
c'était plus simple pour le tournage en
gros j'ai dispatché mon travail en trois
jours premier jour écrire le script
deuxième jour faire le tournage et
troisième jour le montage ça vous a
donné envie d'en faire d'autres
peut-être
ça me donne beaucoup envie après il y a
le temps il y a des problèmes de temps
c'est vrai que en première on est assez
chargé etc mais c'est vrai que dès que
je pense que dès que j'aurai l'occasion
je me dirais pourquoi pas en refaire
plus une autre ou plusieurs peut-être
une carrière dans l'histoire dans aussi
une carrière de youtubeur est-ce qu'il y
a par exemple des youtubers d'histoire
qui vous inspirent peut-être est-ce que
vous en avez vous avez des références
pas spécialement des youtubeurs j'en ai
pas j'ai pas des noms mais c'est vrai
que quand je suis en cours d'histoire et
que j'ai besoin de comprendre une notion
c'est vrai que j'aime bien aller
regarder des des personnes qui
m'expliquent etc mais j'ai pas de j'ai
je ne suis pas quelqu'un en particulier
bravo en tout cas pour cette vidéo je le
rappelle le titre c'est on a toujours la
patate grâce à Parmentier on peut la
retrouver sur notre chaîne YouTube en
intégralité mais surveillez aussi un TV
78 nous la diffuserons également
régulièrement sur la chaîne mais
également sur nos réseaux sociaux merci
Maxence merci beaucoup monsieur en
plateau dans l'émission Vy P very la
base personne Véronique Ithurbide reçoit
et James Hollain il est à la fois
colonel de gendarmerie dirigeant des
unités d'investigation mais aussi auteur
de polar aimez-vous les uns les autres
c'est d'ailleurs le titre de son dernier
roman paru aux éditions caïmans extrait
de l'émission on parle pas de roman
policier il y a écrit polar on parle de
romon noir vous pouvez me définir un
petit peu ce genre du roman noir par
rapport au roman polo policier habituel
bah le roman noir c'est un peu une
catégorie Fourtou je dirais mais qui
subdivise en plusieurs plusieurs
subdivisions de pouvoir répétitions mais
le roman policier on va dire que c'est
le roman énigme Agatha Christie il y a
un meurtre qui a colonel Moutarde devant
c'est le Cluedo il y a le roman noir
plutôt qui a une dimension sociétale qui
va
s'intéresser à un problème un problème
sociétal un peu et puis il y a le roman
noir je dirais le qui vise à faire peur
donc là c'est simple c'est comme une
sorte de film d'horreur il faut créer
faut créer de la peur chez le lecteur il
y a le roman noir humoristique de façon
son Antonio etc
je me suis aperçu que je faisais deux il
y avait deux veines début je voulais
faire comme si non sinon il faisait un
truc sympa il disait il y a les maigres
c'est les romans que j'ai créé en une
semaine en si flottant et puis il y a la
les romans sérieux voilà que que je mets
du temps à les écrire bon moi finalement
c'est le début je voulais faire ça puis
ça va pas c'était voilà c'était pas donc
maintenant en fait finalement il y a
deux deux catégories qui se dessinent il
y a les humoristiques un peu drôle comme
celui-là et puis plutôt sombre pour dire
qu'il y a une veine sombre et une veine
blanche un peu comme pour comme de la BD
et le précédent la pleine balle c'était
plutôt du sombre
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas trop
c'est surtout les
les personnes les individus les ressorts
individuels
émission vypr retrouvé en intégralité
sur notre site Internet TV 78.com et sur
notre application mobile et de la
musique à présent dans le 7 8 il sera
dans les Yvelines le 16 décembre
prochain Alexis HK jouera sur la scène
du théâtre Coluche de plaisir un concert
organisé par la clé des champs qui
débutera à 20h30 et Alexis HK est avec
nous par visioconférence bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous alors vous
présenterez entre autres votre nouvel
album bobo playground je vous propose
histoire qu'on se mette un petit peu
dans l'ambiance d'écouter tout de suite
un extrait cet album et on écoute un
extrait justement du titre bobo
playground le clivage jamais et
réglementaire les crevards qui dit au
pied des barres gris clair et les petits
mignons qui se baignent pavillon en
fumant le pneu pour guépard les machines
premier round sur le bobo les grandes
bourgeois moyen
bourgeois pour email
vous êtes auteur compositeur interprète
vous avez 25 ans de carrière à votre
actif de nombreuses distinctions on peut
citer notamment celle de chevaliers des
Arts et des Lettres en 2016 vous avez
été aussi nommé dans la catégorie
Révélation révélation saine aux
Victoires de la Musique en 2012 et je le
disais vous revenez donc avec cet album
popo playground dans lequel vous vous
interrogez sur sur le bonheur quel est
le message que vous allez vous avez
voulu passer dans cet album
moi je sais pas si passer des messages
c'est vraiment le rôle d'un chanteur
c'est surtout donner un regard en fait
sur les choses un regard subjectif donc
qui n'est pas forcément vrai qui peut
prêter de lieu
et c'est vrai que le clivage
les privilégiés ce qu'on appelle un peu
les bobos aujourd'hui et les autres
c'est
dans l'air du temps et c'est quelque
chose qui qui me parlait et j'avais
envie de j'avais envie de le faire comme
un troubadour c'est à dire avec
en chanson mais c'est surtout pour
parler d'écrivage en chanson avec humour
mais aussi toujours en tendresse et vous
dites vous vous moquez des des bobos qui
sont les bobos dont vous parlez ce qu'on
n'est pas tous un peu bobo au fond
ouais c'est surtout de
je me suis regardé vivre et je me suis
regardé vivre et je me suis dit ouais
toi si on devait te mettre dans une
catégorie je pense que tu devrais
traiter de beau et à partir de là ça m'a
donné envie de reprendre un peu comme
Renault à son époque tous les clichési
Asiatiques journalistique des bobos
parce qu'il y a toute une iconographie
il suffit que vous ayez un meuble design
chez vous ou une paire de beachtock et
vous pouvez vous faire traiter de
Beaubourg et ça ça m'amusait pas mal
mais oui
c'est une valeur
intéressante aujourd'hui parce que comme
tout est devenu un petit peu compliqué
et pour enfin dans le rire dans
l'amusement ou dans le dans les ronies
ils vont se moquer de soi-même d'abord
je pense que c'est ce qui marche mieux
pour pas se faire massacrer sur les
réseaux sociaux et pour pouvoir parler
des choses en disant voilà je sais de
quoi je vous parle parce que parce que
c'est moi quoi en fait
et quand on vous écoute on a
l'impression aussi que aucun mot n'est
choisi au hasard alors quand on lit
votre présentation on vous définit comme
poète funambule on a l'impression que
vous amusez avec la langue française
c'est le cas
oui je fais du texte quelque chose
d'important parce que moi je fais ouais
en chanson le texte est primordial les
mots sont très très important
vous serez donc je le disais en concert
le vendredi 16 décembre sur la scène du
théâtre Coluche le concert débutera à
20h30 alors si on remonte le fil du
temps votre dernier show c'était un
mélange entre concerts one man show et
également à quoi doit-on s'attendre
cette fois-ci pour pour ce show à
plaisir
de cette fameuse idée de jeu pour robot
ça va être un concert basé sur le bien
et c'est un concert inspiré par les plus
grands maîtres du développement
personnel quoi c'est à dire je m'amuse
avec cette notion de bien-être puisque
c'est vraiment une notion pour nous vend
beaucoup aujourd'hui on le vend d'un
côté la fin du monde tous les jours et
en même temps en ouvrant le bien-être
avec plein de techniques pour rester
heureux malgré tout et donc je m'amuse
avec ça pour pouvoir des chansons
pour vous qui êtes né dans les Yvelines
si je ne m'abuse arrêtez moi si je me
trompe je crois que vous êtes né à
Poissy c'est particulier d'aller à la
rencontre du public yvelinois de vous
produire dans les Yvelines à chaque fois
c'est un retour aux sources c'est oui
c'est particulier parce que c'est pas
n'importe où et les Yvelines c'est chez
moi quoi c'est mes origines c'est là que
j'ai grandi moi j'ai grandi à
Verneuil-sur-Seine donc pas très très
loin de plaisir pas très loin de
Versailles et donc ouais c'est un retour
aux sources je sais qu'il y aura de la
famille je sais qu'il y aura peut-être
des vieux amis c'est forcément un peu
particulier mais en janvier 2023 vous
retrouverez l'Olympia j'y retrouverai
parce que vous êtes déjà produit à
l'Olympia vous avez hâte
oui j'ai retrouvé ça va être une grande
soirée
ça va être une grande soirée ou là
encore il faut profiter un maximum c'est
une chance pour n'importe quel chanteur
et c'est une chance qu'il faut pas
laisser passer moi j'en fais pas 5 sur 8
j'en fais 15 heures donc je compte bien
en profiter oui j'ai hâte tout à fait
merci Alexis HK d'avoir été avec nous
malgré une connexion un peu mauvaise ce
soir mais merci d'avoir été avec nous et
je le rappelle vous serez sur la scène
du théâtre Coluche à plaisir ce sera le
vendredi 16 décembre un concert organisé
par la clé des champs qui est débutera à
20h30 toutes les informations à
retrouver sur le site internet du
théâtre Coluche de plaisir
et on en parlait en début d'émission la
compagnie Pixum va donner un nouveau
spectacle immersif au Petit Moulin des
Vaux de Cernay ce sera du 16 décembre au
15 janvier avec nous pour en parler elle
est revenue également en plateau c'est
Charlie formant qui est directrice
artistique de la compagnie Pixum le
temps des humains c'est le nom de ce
spectacle qui se déroule en 22 2023 sur
terre c'est ça l'espèce humaine a
disparu voilà histoire de planter le
décor quel est le pitch du spectacle
j'ai quand même un petit peu planté le
décor mais comment pourrait-on présenter
et l'espèce d'après les humains ceux qui
viendront après nous
trouvent des objets beaucoup des déchets
que on a laissé derrière nous et il se
demande bien à quoi ça peut servir donc
c'est une c'est une exposition
archéologique où l'espèce d'après les
spécialistes de l'espèce d'après se
demandent mais à quoi pouvait bien
servir tous les objets du quotidien des
humains et on les regarde en les disait
qu'on se pose des questions sur à quoi
pouvait bien servir ses objets pour les
humains et profite nous artiste pour
faire passer un message écologique sur
se poser la question de tous ces objets
qui font notre quotidien et qui sont pas
forcément très utiles et très voilà très
bon pour la planète quoi derrière
j'imagine c'est aussi de pousser la
réflexion sur notre société aujourd'hui
c'est la réflexion sur notre rapport à
l'objet bien sûr notre rapport à la
nature
et notre rapport aussi aux uns aux
autres et un peu aux archétypes qui font
de notre société et comment comment on
évolue aujourd'hui société allemand
voilà on parle beaucoup de la fin du
monde est-ce qu'on peut en parler avec
le sourire est-ce qu'on peut en parler
d'une façon un peu bonne enfant qui
fasse avancer vraiment les choses de
façon interactive où on peut réfléchir
ensemble et pas de façon culpabilisante
comme on peut le voir parfois avec aussi
la découverte d'un nouveau monde un
guide d'une nouvelle espèce comment vous
l'avez imaginé cette nouvelle espèce
c'est un humain 3.0 un petit peu ouais
alors c'est c'est on les appelle les
fausses muscles et ils sont c'est des
espèces de champignons qui ont qui ont
évolué avec une espèce de dérive
plastique parce qu'il y avait tellement
de plastique sur terre qu'ils ont leur
corps évolué avec leur un mélange de
plastique et de fondue voilà et on les
appelle les fausses muscles et ils sont
très attachants et voilà il se posent
énormément de questions sur les humains
et ils ont pas forcément tout compris
sur comment ça fonctionnait pour nous
mais ils sont ils sont très volontaires
ils sont très envie de comprendre et ils
demandent d'ailleurs au public leurs
idées sur telle ou tel objet à quoi
pouvait-il servir voilà donc nous en
tant que compagnie on a détourné
beaucoup d'objets qu'on récupère et
qu'on va mixer ensemble pour pour créer
des voilà des objets un peu curieux et
où on se pose des questions sur sur leur
utilisation dans notre vie et dans le
spectacle et on parle là d'une
expérience immersive c'est un spectacle
immersif comment justement les
spectateurs vous en avez un peu parlé
mais comment sont-ils associés justement
à ce spectacle alors nous ça sera comme
une expo en fait donc les gens arrive
comme pour une expo sauf que quand ils
arrivent il y a une machine à voyager
dans le temps et ils sont embarqués dans
une aventure où on leur demande d'être
participant de l'aventure on va leur
poser des questions on va leur demander
leurs idées et aussi on va lui faire
participer
plus physiquement en leur demandant de
ramener un objet de chez eux qui va
faire partie du spectacle qu'ils vont
laisser dans le dans le lieu pour
participer à la construction de ce décor
on voit l'image l'un des spectacles que
vous avez pu proposer sur sur le thème
d'Halloween spectacle également immersif
et on a l'impression qu'il y a de plus
en plus de spectacles immersif on en
relais souvent dans cette émission du 7
8 pourquoi c'est intéressant justement
d'associer le spectateur qu'est-ce qui
vous intéresse maintenant je pense qu'on
est dans la précovie et que c'est
intéressant aujourd'hui de proposer
autre chose au spectateur qui
aujourd'hui on a tous nettoyé chez nous
on peut tous
regarder la télé se faire raconter une
histoire avec des effets spéciaux ça
c'est possible aujourd'hui pour tout le
monde chez soi alors aujourd'hui en tant
qu'artiste qu'est-ce qu'on propose à la
population qui va changer un peu la
donne qui fait qu'on va voir des gens
qu'on va participer à quelque chose on
va avoir une vraie expérience physique
et qu'on va partager avec d'autres
humains finalement et ça c'est une
expérience je pense que les gens
recherchent aujourd'hui la particularité
aussi de ce spectacle c'est que vous
avez mêlé théâtre danse art plastique
numérique également c'est ça ouais on
mélange plein de médias ensemble
parce qu'on a des comédiens on a des
danseuses là sur ce projet on a aussi du
chant et on a beaucoup de plasticiens
qui viennent pour créer ces décors ça a
été le cas aussi sur la maison hantée
pour Halloween ou on a un côté plastique
très très fort parce qu'on fait du
théâtre d'objets donc on récupère des
objets qu'on va avoir grâce à un
partenariat qu'on a avec la Ressourcerie
du Perray qui va nous fournir de l'objet
que nous on va revaloriser
artistiquement et qui du coup fait une
valorisation écologique de la même façon
puisqu'on récupère des objets qui
seraient voués à un autre destin et on
les on les reprend dans un circuit court
et on les on les revalorise voilà et
combien de comédiens de danseurs sur ce
spectacle
voilà dans la maison hantée ils étaient
une dizaine donc ça dépend des projets
quoi voilà et donc ce sera à retrouver
le temps des humains du 16 décembre au
15 janvier les vendredi samedi dimanche
et donc au Petit Moulin des Vaux de
Cernay merci Charlie formenty d'être
venu en parler en plateau et je le
rappelle vous êtes la directrice
artistique de la compagnie Pixon qui
propose ce spectacle d'ailleurs si vous
souhaitez réserver votre place
rendez-vous sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran le billet je
parle sous vos contrôle via adulte au
tarif de 5 euros pour les enfants merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci
[Musique]
comme chaque mardi TV 78 va la rencontre
des chefs du territoire pour qu'il
dévoile quelques-uns de leur secret pour
briller en cuisine ce soir c'est
Jean-Baptiste Lavergne Morazzani le chef
étoilé de la table du 11 à Versailles
qui se prête à l'exercice il nous livre
ça recète du topinambour et œuf fermier
à reproduire chez vous regardez
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue je suis Jean-Baptiste
Lavergne Morazzani du restaurant La
Table du 11 à Versailles où on a
également le Bistrot du 11 et la cave du
11 et aujourd'hui on va faire une
recette autour du topinambour et de
l'infirmier
[Musique]
on va cuire assez simplement
moitié eau moitié lait
[Musique]
c'est des oignons rôtis qu'on vient
mouiller à l'eau et on laisse cuire le
jus pendant au moins deux jours
[Musique]
on va transformer en huile donc là on va
passer par le froid par la congélation
pour avoir vraiment le côté très vert on
le congèle avec l'huile de pépin de
raisin une fois que les feuilles sont
blanchies ensuite on vient le mixer et
du coup on a une huile qui est très
verte parce que c'est bloqué par le
froid ensuite on va commencer notre
topping
donc on va commencer par Lacazette donc
on est sur une noisette bio de Bourgogne
[Musique]
donc on vient griller et ensuite réduit
en poudre achèterez fin donc là l'idée
c'est vraiment d'apporter des textures à
notre plat on a quelque chose d'assez
crémeux d'assez lisse là on va apporter
du topping sur le dessus pour avoir un
côté un petit peu plus croustillant
donc on vient caraméliser ensuite on les
égoutte on les met sur papier on les
déshydrate
[Musique]
pareil on vient déshydrater de
l'estragon frais un très court moment au
four on va laisser pendant 6 minutes à
160 degrés donc pour garder la couleur
très verte
[Musique]
on vient le confire à basse température
à 70 degrés dans une huile d'olive Corse
de l'altaro donc le sud de la Corse on
va venir le déposer tout doucement tout
délicatement sur le haut de l'assiette
et voici le topinambour avec l'infirmier
donc la petite astuce que j'ai à vous
donner c'est pour avoir une huile très
verte de basilique c'est de passer par
la congélation donc n'oubliez pas de
blanchir vos feuilles de basilic ensuite
vous les mouillez à hauteur avec l'huile
de pépin de raisin c'est multi captera
le plus de goût et seulement le
lendemain une fois que cette huile est
réserves sont congelées ou mixez et vous
passez dans un chinois étamine je vous
souhaite bon appétit
[Musique]
non merci à Jean-Baptiste Lavergne
morazani ça nous a donné fin quelques
minutes avant de passer à table avant de
vous laisser un dernier petit tour par
la météo de demain
[Musique]
bon quelque chose de moins heureux
demain dans les Yvelines avec un ciel
terre brumeux à Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan
et Rambouillet demain matin du côté de
Versailles les nuages seront présents au
niveau des températures couvrez-vous
bien car il fera 2 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles et un
degré à Houdan et Rambouillet et dans
l'après-midi le ciel va rester couvert
sur l'ensemble du département l'hiver
s'installe bien au niveau des
températures il fera de 5 à 4 degrés en
moyenne et demain nous fêterons les
Ambroise voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission le 7 8 merci de votre fidélité
on se retrouve bien sûr dès demain pour
une nouvelle édition très belle soirée
sur TV 78
[Musique]